c'était son combat politique actuelle la
création d'un nouveau département issu
du rapprochement des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
cette fusion patrick devedjian l'espérer
d'ici à la fin 2020 un voeu commun avec
le président du département des yvelines
pierre bédier rappelé lors d'une
cérémonie le 14 janvier dernier à la
scène musicale de boulogne-billancourt
eh bien écoutez si vous n'avez pas
compris que notre souhait principal
c'était d'obtenir enfin cette fusion que
nous avons engagées mais maintenant il y
a trois ans et avec 90% de nos élus et
qui va un peu transformé la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens
ce projet est lancé en 2016 par les
présidents des deux collectivités
une création acté au mois de mars à
travers un établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines hauts de
seine on n'est pas encore dans une
fusion
on est simplement dans un processus de
rapprochement
nous avons un instrument pour travailler
ensemble et déterminer ce que pourra
être dans l'avenir une fusion si nous
réussissons à la mener à son terme
plusieurs compétences sont mutualisés
l'archéologie préventive le service
adoption et l'entretien des routes
départementales
viennent ensuite la création d'un
aménageur urbain commun baptisé site
alios ou encore dernièrement la
transformation d'activité en une agence
d'insertion interdépartemental on prend
ce qu'il ya de mieux dans le département
kellal mieux traités par exemple nous
dans les hauts-de-seine
on a beaucoup gagné au système
d'insertion des yvelines et donc nous
nous avons harmonisé nos deux
dispositifs et nous prenons celui des
yvelines qui est meilleur que notre
efficacité de l'action publique liberté
des collectivités locales des valeurs
défendues par patrick devedjian dans son
parcours politique
suite à sa disparition pierre bédier à
l'espoir de poursuivre le combat de son
homologue alto séquanais sur la fusion
et le dossier de la métropole du grand
paris il était mon ami et ensemble nous
avons porté le combat pour une métropole
parisienne digne de ce nom c'est à dire
rayonnante ambitieuse juste et pour le
rapprochement de nos deux départements
si complémentaires honorer sa mémoire
c'est poursuivre son combat pour être
officialisé la fusion des deux
départements doit être décrétée par le
gouvernement dans le contexte actuel la
question pourrait être tranchée qu'en
fin d'année voire en 2021